What if I told you that all the magical breath
attacks that you see and How To Train Your Dragon
are real? Ice breath, fire breath, lightning,
acid, sound. All of them are just waiting for
you to unlock. In fact, most of them aren't even
that hard to achieve. Just get ready for a little
dose of science on the way. What can I say?
We're theorists. It's an occupational hazard.
Hello Internet! Welcome to Film Theory. The
show that's been drag-on you to learn things
since 2015. You know, when it comes to fantasy
creatures, nothing is quite as iconic as the
dragon. And right now, they seem to be undergoing
a bit of a renaissance in pop culture. House of
the Dragon basically saved the Game of Thrones IP.
There are whispers of a new Spyro game in
the works. There's the new Dungeons & Dragons
movie with a TV show not far behind. And the TV
Livestream Critical Role has had two seasons of
their show adapted into the genuinely fantastic
Legend of Vox Machina. Even Universal was starting
to get in on the trend, announcing that they're
going to go the Disney route by giving How
to Train Your Dragon a live action remake.
And that's in addition to the 19 seasons of
television that they've already made out of
this thing. And so with all this dragon talk
going on, I decided to re-binge the entire How
to Train Your Dragon series. And of course,
my theorist brain started to do the thing
that all theorist brains do. It started
overanalyzing everything about the film.
Specifically, I was fascinated by all the
different breath attacks that the Dragons
in the world seem to have. Sure, you've
got yourself your classic fire breath,
but over the course of the series we also
learn about dragons who use boiling water,
electricity, ice, acid, even sound. The creatures
that use all these attacks are also really diverse
in terms of their size and appearance.
Which got me wondering, is any of this
actually possible? What would animals who use
these sorts of attacks actually look like? How
to Train Your Dragon puts a surprising amount
of care into their dragon designs. But do they
actually hold up to real world scrutiny? Well,
saddle up loyal theorists. Today we're looking at
the biology of these dragons to see which of the
breath attacks are the most biologically sound.
And let me tell you, if dragons like the
ones that we see here existed in the real
world, the most effective power isn't the one
that you'd expect. So I think we should just go
ahead and get the granddaddy of all dragon
breath attacks out of the way first here:
the iconic fire breath. Now obviously no lizard
or reptile in nature actually straight up
breathes fire like a dragon. That's an entirely
fictional thing from myth, but believe it or not,
this sort of thing is very feasible in nature.
And we can see this thanks to an itty bitty
little insect called the Bombardier Beetle. Now,
I’ve already talked about this in detail in an
episode about the terrifying truth of Fire Pokemon
over on our sister location gAmE tHeOry, so just
to quickly sum this one up. When threatened, the
Bombardier beetle shoots out scalding chemicals
at its foes. It does this by using three organs in
its abdomen. Two of those organs are glands that
produce hydroquinones and hydrogen peroxide.
The third organ is where those two chemicals
mix together. When combined, they perform a
reduction-oxidation reaction, which basically
means that they get themselves really, really hot.
The Bombardier Beetle then shoots that liquid at
whatever threat they perceive. Now, what the
Bombardier Beetle shoots is a heated liquid,
which lines up well with the Scauldrons that
we hear about in How to Train Your Dragon.
But what about more actual fire? Well, this
same concept could work with a variety of
different chemical combinations. For instance,
potassium chlorate and ordinary table sugar,
when combined with a drop of sulfuric acid
releases large quantities of heat energy
in the form of awesome purple flames, like
legitimately a purple flame spewing dragon
would be awesome! On the less awesome but still
very biologically feasible side are farts.
You see, in a short we released earlier
this week, we took a closer look at the
new Dungeons & Dragons movie to see just how its
dragon uses fire breath. Based on the footage
that we see in the film, you can see that it
breathes out a clear gas that it then ignites
using a spark in the back of its throat or
just general heat in the world around it.
That gas that it's spewing, that's likely methane.
A gas that occurs naturally in almost all animals
in the form of farts. It's clear, it's flammable.
And, well, it would bring new meaning to the
phrase dragon breath. I guess the old saying
is true. Why fart and waste it? We can burp and
light it on fire to scorch your foes to death.
So now that we figured out a few mechanisms for
fire breath, time to get creative, what
about some of the more unusual types of
breath attacks that we see in these movies? like,
say, Electric Breath. It's something that we see
in fantasy media all the time. The Legend of
Vox Machina begins with a giant blue dragon.
And nothing is more iconic than Yo-Gi-Oh!'s Blue
Eyes, White Dragon in its white lightning attack.
Except both of these examples result in one major
problem. Electricity is unpredictable. Electric
charges are created when electrons jump between
objects. Since electrons are negatively charged
particles, having fewer electrons creates a
positive electric charge and having a bunch
of extra electrons creates a negative charge. And
when the difference between the positive and the
negative get big enough, the electrons jump to
bounce themselves out, to become neutral again.
The problem is it'll do this with literally
anything it can find. The electricity doesn't
care. It'll just go to the closest thing that
it can trade electrons with. But for an electric
breath attack to work, the dragons wouldn't just
need to change its electron count. It would also
need a way to make sure that its target was
the best option to transfer electrons with.
And the only way to do that would be by
manipulating the amount of electrons the
target has. That said, directing lightning
can be done. Back in January of 2012, reports
started to circulate about the U.S. Army testing
a lightning weapon, one that was able to attack
using 50 billion watts of energy. How did they
manage to control the lightning? using a laser.
It was called the laser induced plasma
channel or LIPC for short. Basically how
it worked was that a laser would put out a pulse
of energy. This pulse had to be incredibly brief,
only about 2 trillionth of a second, but that
was enough to create a path for the lightning
to follow. Before that, in 1993, the US Air
Force and Naval Weapons Research divisions
both successfully conducted tests into plasma
rail guns, devices intended to capture plasma
and then launch it in specific directions.
Basically, they were trying to weaponize
balls of lightning that were hotter than the
surface of the sun and could detonate with
an explosive force of 5 lbs of TNT on contact.
All while discharging an electromagnetic burst
that could scramble most electronic devices
in the area. And while that was certainly
impressive. What was even more impressive was
this thing's name Project M.A.R.A.U.D.E.R.
with Marauder actually being a real acronym
that stood for real words that made sense.
Get this: Magnetically Accelerated Ring To
Achieve Ultra High Directed Energy And Radiation.
Slow clap.
I hope that someone got a raise for
coming up with that one. And while both projects
did wind up being successful, the only problem
were the power demands. They were too high for
weapons that had such limited range, which made
'em impractical, and the projects went away.
In short, the best way of making a lightning
weapon work for both the military and by
extension, our Dragon friends is to get
really darn close to the intended target, which
then encourages the lightning to jump over to
them. And there are creatures that do this exact
thing. The most famous of these is obviously the
electric eel, which is able to release powerful
electric shocks upwards of 650 volts, five times
more powerful than a standard U.S. wall socket.
It then uses those shocks to stun their prey
so they can eat them. Believe it or not, this
actually lines up really well with what we see
in How to Train Your Dragon. Rather than launching
targeted lightning beams from his mouth, Toothless
is instead able to create smaller electric
sparks around its body. In The Hidden World,
Toothless seems to create electric potentials
all across his own body, resulting in electricity
crackling across his skin before lightning
from a storm cloud ultimately hits him.
In short, How to Train Your Dragon gives us
the most realistic portrayal of what a dragon's
lightning powers would have to look like in
real life. Moving on to the coolest of the
attacks that we see in these movies, Ice Breath.
See what I did there? I said, cool and you thought
that I meant cool as in awesome, but I meant
literally cool like from a temperature basis.
Thermodynamically cool. Just wanted you all to
appreciate the layered nuance that goes into these
streamy award winning scripts. Anyway and How to
Train Your Dragon 2 We meet the Bewilderbeasts,
giant dragons that breathe out supercooled
liquid that's able to freeze on contact.
Now I know what you’re saying, a reptile
that breathes ice, sounds impossible.
And you're not wrong. As cold blooded animals,
reptiles and ice just don't mix all that well.
You ever seen a lizard just out in the wild
hanging out on a rock, baking in the sun?
It's doing that to get heat from the rock
in the sun to regulate its body temperature,
somewhere between 12.5 to 35 degrees
Celsius or 54.5 to 95 degrees Fahrenheit,
depending on what animal you're talking about,
much higher than the temperature of ice.
But if we stop and take a look at how
the Bewilderbeasts act in the movie,
we can actually find a scientifically feasible
explanation for this breath weapon. In fact,
it would actually function very similarly to fire
breath except in reverse. You see explosions and
fire. Well, those are exothermic reactions.
They're chemical reactions that release a ton
of heat. To create ice breath that freezes on
contact our dragons would need to create the
exact opposite reaction than that, an endothermic
reaction where the reactants absorb heat energy
from their surroundings, thereby making things
colder. And we actually have the perfect example
of this in our day to day lives using instant
ice packs. If you've ever gotten into an injury,
these things are clutch. And the beauty
of them is that they're just super simple.
The liquid inside the cold pack is just water,
easy. But inside the water is another tube that
contains ammonium nitrate, a common ingredient
of fertilizer. When you bend the ice pack and
cause the inner tube to break, that ammonium
nitrate salt dissolves into the water around
it to create an endothermic chemical reaction
that absorbs heat. This reaction then causes
the water to cool down and the pack becomes ice.
Now just look at the Bewilderbeast as he breathes.
He's breathing out a liquid that freezes into
ice on contact, just like with the fire breath,
the dragon could store water in one side
of its body and the ammonium nitrate in
another. That would then allow the dragon
to keep a stable internal body temperature
despite being a cold blooded creature.
The chemical reaction that creates the
ice isn't happening until after it breathes out
those two reactants. It’s a cool attack that
would be powered by even cooler science. And heck,
if the animal needed more protection, maybe it's
insulated with layers of blubber like some ancient
reptilian dinosaurs had. That would explain why
the Bewilderbeasts are just so naturally big. But
now let's switch gears into something completely
different, something that really starts to get
us out of the realm of fantasy. In the original
How to Train Your Dragon the Thunderdrum
Dragon uses a sound based breath weapon.
Surprise. We already have animals in the real
world that use sound like a gun. Case in point,
the pistol shrimp. This little guy is no joke.
And its power comes from this massive claw.
When it wants to intimidate an opponent,
attack prey, or even burrow into a rock,
it's able to snap the claws shut quickly enough
to shoot an air bubble at whatever it's aiming
at. At long ranges that makes a loud, scary sound,
but at short range it can stun or flat out kill
any other small shrimp or fish. Again, exactly
like what we hear about with the Thunderdrum.
And when you look at the science here, it's easy
to see how they're so lethal. The snap of a claw
produces a sound that can reach 218 decibels in
volume underwater. Just how loud is that? Well,
a whisper. It's roughly 30 decibels. A normal
conversation is about 60 decibels and a rock
concert hits at around 120 decibels, but decibels
rise exponentially. That means that a ten decibel
increase makes the sound ten times louder.
The 218 decibel pistol shrimp is roughly 10
billion times louder than the 120 decibel concert.
Yeah, you heard that right. Billion with a B. Now,
the numbers there aren't going to exactly
line up 1 to 1 with what you'd probably expect
because sound works differently underwater.
It's muffled by the different pressures. But
the sound is powerful enough that American
submarines used to use reefs full of pistol
shrimp to hide from Japanese sonar. And as you
can see here in this video, the pops made by
the pistol shrimp are incredibly loud compared to
their size, audible even through aquarium glass.
*Snap*
If a dragon were able to reproduce this sort
of attack above the water, maybe by snapping
its jaw shut quickly, it would be devastating.
And as an added bonus, we see in How to Train
Your Dragon that the Dragons rely on sound
as one of their primary senses while hunting.
So not only would the sound potentially be
deadly, but it's also going to be devastating
for any opponent's navigational abilities.
Which brings us now to one of the easiest
attacks to explain using science: acid breath. in
How To Train Your Dragon 3 the villainous Grimmel
has several tamed Deathgripper dragons that
spew acid that's able to corrode through almost
anything it touches. Now, while the strength
of the Deathgripper acid is definitely cranked
up to 11 for the movies, this sort of offensive
ability is pretty darn common across the animal
kingdom. Several insects like termites, ants
and scorpions are able to spray or sting with
acid. While many species of cobra are just
able to accurately spew their acidic venom
several feet away. Even some birds, like the
Fulmar Petrel and Turkey Vulture, can vomit up
stomach acid and use it as a projectile weapon.
That is pretty darn gross. It is also pretty darn
similar to what we see the Deathgrippers do in
the movies, so don't really need to explain it
much further than that. So as it turns out, these
sorts of breath weapons are shockingly plausible
in real life. There are real world animals out
there right now using these very attacks like
the pistol shrimp and the spitting cobra.
And if they're not using the exact attack,
then they're using mechanisms that are pretty darn
close to what we see happening in fantasy media,
like with the bombardier beetle and the electric
eel. But you know what they say, truth can
be stranger than fiction. And in the case of
dragons, all of us are sleeping on the terror
that is the real life dragon, the komodo dragon.
While we're busy creating fantasy worlds like
Berk. These guys are just hanging out in Indonesia
and while we're concocting explanations for fire
breath and freeze breath and lightning rays, these
lumbering monitor lizards are just decimating the
competition not with breath attacks, but with
the bite attacks. The Komodo dragon has a very
powerful venom that's generated in several ducts
between their teeth, injecting that venom into
anything it wants to eat or just eat later.
The venom contains over 50 different toxic
proteins, a deadly mix that rapidly decreases
the blood pressure of its victim, expediting
blood loss and sending their bodies into shock,
rendering the prey too weak to fight back. The
Komodo dragon then just rolls over and eats them
at their leisure. And the craziest part of it all,
it is so effective that the bite doesn't even
need to be that strong. Studies have shown that
the Komodo dragon's bite is weaker than that
of the common housecat. As long as it pierces
the skin, it's all it needs. In the end for as
fantastical as dragons may seem in pop culture,
the science is right there in the nature around
us. Sure, the pistol shrimp might not be sitting
atop his hoard of gold and you might not be able
to ride a komodo dragon as majestically through
the air as Hiccup on top of Toothless.
But the animal world is crazy, and we're
understanding more about the wonders of how
it works every single day. In this world full
of technology and screens and CGI, we often
overlook that our world is already a really
cool place filled with incredible creatures.
Sometimes it takes a fictional series to help
us appreciate the real life wonders around us.
But hey! that doesn't mean that we should be
depriving ourselves of the fantasy. And you can
get more dragon goodness right now, thanks to the
sponsor of today's episode Call of Dragons,
this new MMO fantasy conquest game for iOS,
Android and PC is from the creators of Rise
of Kingdoms and it plays like a 4x strategy
game mashed together with the best elements
of MMO RPGs, allowing you to explore a new
fantasy world all while recruiting elven maidens,
mighty orcs and powerful mages to your cause.
But the real selling point here, dragons.
I mean, come on, it's in the name Call
of Dragons. The game features a ton of giant
behemoth monsters that you can tame and unleash
onto the battlefield, including giant bears,
thunder rocs and of course, the fire breathing
dragon. Let me tell you, there is nothing more
satisfying than getting a dragon out onto the
field and changing the tide of battle.
Well, maybe one day when I'm able to get
my hands on that lightning railgun. Yeah,
that'd be pretty darn cool. But until then,
there is Call of Dragons. Between running
these channels and spending time with the
family. Let me tell you, I don't have a ton
of time to play games anymore, especially the
really in-depth RPGs that I grew up loving.
But having a game like Call of Dragons on
my phone where I can play in between meetings and
recordings, it's awesome. I highly recommend that
you check it out by going to their official
website by scanning the QR code that you see
on screen right now, or clicking the link in
the description below and using the promo code
TFTPlayCod for a special bonus. That's TFTPlayCod.
Thank you again to Call of Dragons for sponsoring
today's episode and I'll see you all next
week with a brand new installment. Until then,
as always, my friends remember, it's all
just a theory A FILM THEORY! aaaaaaand cut.